I just got back from the Middle East we
had to buy new outfits for all my
dancers because they were so you know so
sexy I am
Luis FONSI and this is gqueues the
process this mesito means slowly just
slowing it down slowing life down
slowing the relationship down slowing
that night down from the moment you meet
that person just enjoying and savoring
every second of it I woke up one morning
with this spa seat and then in the
Puerto Rico bendito that's all I had so
I like literally ran to my studio I just
made sure I recorded that before I
forgot it that afternoon I met with
Erika and ER it was an amazing
songwriter she played me some ideas she
had I was like but wait I had this idea
called this Posse to play the part of my
guitar there's something there you know
let's let's work on this for hours in we
had this Posse though we're Latin people
man we knew we do writing sessions with
with a bottle of whiskey or wrong but
then Erik and I just kind of built a
scenario what I can't we're in a club
and there's this guy and this girl when
looking at each other and so they're
selling - hurting my dad we're
connecting hey let's do this but let's
take it
there's besitos you almost have to build
characters sometimes I give the
characters names it's like the
equivalent of like an actor researching
the role 99 98 percent of the songs that
I've written are melody first lyric
second this bossy dough it just came it
was born together it was born this spa
season I write this Pacita with Erica it
actually started sounding like a cumbia
cumbia it's like ting ting to t you know
had that vibe this is PI C DT so I
recorded the demo this way and I just
left it under storage and Mauricio
drinkie for are the producers of of this
Macedo I play them very raw demo and
they're like the song is amazing I'm
again but I just don't know where to
take it and they're like that just
that's neat that needs a beat you know
that sound just needs like it
wrong beat to make people dance I sat
with the guys and I was like mm what
would happen if we take out the second
verse and we have a featuring on this
song I had worked with daddy yankee so I
took a chance and I called him I sent
him to track I was like look this song
is special it just needs that last sort
of explosion that I can't do and that
you can the very first thing was what we
call the pluck which is that we just
laid that down undress he just started
laying that sort of ring at all but he
came up with a sound that's a little bit
different than the traditional ringing
it on them bow that's how they call it
in the first chorus we don't hit the one
this claw like it comes in on the upbeat
not on the downbeat they changed it up
enough so it just feels refreshing it
doesn't feel like it's something that
you've heard before and the Quadra idea
was actually one of the last ideas and
probably the most important part of the
song quadrille guitar is such an
important instrument from Puerto Rico
because it's like it's used for
traditional music it's not used for
popular music it just has that
particular sound that just takes you to
your childhood there's a line that goes
[Music]
and to me that is the glue that initial
Ritardando before the first course you
know when the beat is going and just
goes this ba seat to me that's so
important and it works perfect because
what I'm saying is slowly so we slowed
down the beginning when that beat drops
it just makes it that much bigger when
we start recording it and actually start
tweaking it and with final vocals and
doing all the Bee Gees and you know the
background vocals I always record more
than what we're gonna need you just give
the mixer a bunch of you know ideas and
then they can kind of pick and choose
and we do a bunch of like haze and and
just ad-libs and
it's fun obviously when daddy yankee
comes in we had a restructure of the
song because he came up with really cool
parts when we were in the studio and he
started coming up with the rap he just
kind of stood in front of a wall and
just started going and he just started
just shouting stuff out and when he came
up with something so calm about I know
that the producers I was like you know
we're gonna have to go back and do that
with the whole track we already had
everything mixed so we had to go back
open up the session and make sure that
the whole track went and now every time
you hear that part you just you have to
like move with it
producers artists songwriters we like to
mess around with the track and we're
never done with it until somebody just
says stop at some point you just have to
say let's mix like let's just give it to
the engineer to mix let's master it's
like taking your kid to school you know
no maybe it's like the first day of
school it's like oh I just let them go
so when I wrote this song I was a
hundred percent thinking of my Latin
audience it just didn't even cross my
mind that this song was gonna cross over
seeing not only the United States but
just the world sing a song in Spanish
it's so huge for Latin music that's what
I'm mostly proud of that I was a part of
a song that really broke the language
barrier and that to me is the biggest
thing of this besito I'm still shocked I
can't stay here and act like this is
normal the fact that people in Russia
are singing and dancing this song given
you know what I mean like how different
culturally we are not only the language
thing which is the way the sexy dancing
on the video and this and that and I
think that's beautiful that they're
still loving this song the song was
released January 13th mid-april I got a
call from my record label saying hey um
we just got a call from Justin Bieber's
camp that he heard the song in a club
while he was in Colombia he loved it he
saw how everybody just reacted and he
wants to do the remix and I was like
what I was like yeah let's go for it we
sent him the session he's like yeah he's
gonna record it tonight he's gonna do it
he knows what he wants to do just let
him be I was like cool just send me you
know whatever he doesn't see what
happens
next night I get his version I'm
thinking that he's gonna do that the
English version of this procedure I hear
and I hear this new verse in the
beginning and then when the course
starts he's singing it in Spanish and
I'm like what that's gold
he didn't really change it up he just
added the correct ingredients and that's
what took the song to the next level
that picture was taken the day of the
video shoot we knew that we needed a
shot to release that day we just kind of
sat there dy and I and we just tried to
look cool I mean he always looks cool
he's definite don't start I have to work
hard on the looking cool thing cause as
I get let me just look over here and
kind of do the squinty thing and take a
picture and there it goes it's messy to
cover I just got back from the Middle
East we had to buy new outfits for all
my dancers because they were so you know
so sexy and we wanted to make sure we
didn't insult anybody and we have to be
very respectful when I go to Latin
American audiences they'll know every
single song from top to bottom when I go
to these newer countries newer markets
I'm not gonna lie I was a little
skeptical I was like I was a little
frayed Budapest I was like I don't know
how these people are gonna react it was
packed sold-out eight nine thousand
people
[Music]
from the very beginning they were on
their feet singing dancing and it was
like oh man this is again the power of
music you know music unites that was
probably my most important shows in my
career
it wasn't my traditional audience first
time they get to see me perform live
they really just know a few songs but
they just enjoyed it from top to bottom
so it was it was really cool the way I
work when it comes to the visual side of
the music video I get together with my
director and I just give them sort of
how I felt when I wrote the song the
song from the beginning was paying
homage to Puerto Rico
the bridge you know vamos a la una play
in Puerto Rico so I called one of my
closest friends who happens to be one of
the most amazing directors I know Carlos
Perez I said look man I have this really
special song I'm sure you hear this all
the time but I have this really special
song we have to do it in in in Puerto
Rico I wanted to be the streets the
people that dancing like where I grew up
and he got it right away we started
talking about sort of this female figure
we needed this beautiful model to kind
of bring everything together and I
called sue like are you ADA I'm like sue
so I got this song it's a really special
song we need you we she's like I've
heard it ten times in a row I can't turn
it off I love it call me in yes really a
party from the moment we got there to
the moment we finished we just kept on
dancing bossy bossy I don't consider
myself a dancer I just I dance I'm not
enum and we dance we all dance it's like
if you don't dance
you're weird a lot of the stuff was
improvised you know we're just having a
good time it was about dancing coming
together and I'm really proud of it and
I'm glad that it broke every single
viewing record on YouTube the video has
4.5 billion views I still say it and
it's tough not to smile when I say 4.5
billion views
I am Luis FONSI and this was my process